we always knew that Shanks was
overpowered but the big reveal of his
true secret power really shocked
everyone Shanks has incredibly Advanced
observation hockey which allows him to
see into the future for a significant
period of time as chapter 1079
demonstrated we're not talking about
only like a second here Shanks can use
observation hockey to see an entire
scenario play out on the battlefield and
if he doesn't like the outcome he can
act to change that scenario before it
even takes place Shanks uses this
ability to completely defeat Captain
Kidd and the kid pirates in a matter of
seconds and all this despite the fact
that kid was built up as one of the
strongest supernovas who just helped
take down two yonko back in wano Oda
really wants us to know that Shanks is
one of the strongest forces in the
entire world and that he has a big role
to play in the final Arc subscribe to
anime uproar right now for more
one-piece videos